Here's the picture so far.
We have a primal program over
here trying to be maximized, and
we have a dual program over here
trying to be minimized, and
the obvious question
is do they ever meet?
Well, the answer here is yes,
they always do.
More precisely, we state this as
follows in the duality theorem.
If either the primal problem or
the dual has a finite optimum solution.
Then so does the other.
And, the optimum objective
values are equal.
And if either problem has
an unbounded objective value,
then the other is infeasible.
Note that it is possible for both the
primal and the dual to be infeasible.
We'll start the proof by
showing the second part.
If either problem has
an unbounded objective value,
then the other has no feasible solution.
So we'll suppose that
the primal is unbounded and
that y is feasible for the dual.
Well, by weak duality,
b transpose y must be
at least c T times x for all feasible x.
But since the primal is bounded,
there has to be an x that's larger.
And that creates a contradiction.
The case where the dual instead of
primal is unbounded is analogous.
Now we turn to the first
part of the proof.
And we want to show that
if either the primal or
the dual has a finite optimal solution,
then so does the other, and
even more that the optimum
values are equal.
Let's start with the primal
having a finite optimal solution.
Well, that then implies that it has
a finite optimal basic solution
by the Fundamental Theorem
of Linear Programming.
Let's let the basis be the first
m columns of the matrix a, and
we'll divide up x and
c in the usual way.
Remember that B stands for basic here.
Recall then from the simplex
algorithm that this vector r D,
which represented the effects of moving
along one of the directions in x D
had to be non-positive Otherwise
this basic solution wasn't optimal.
Now we're actually going to
construct a solution for the dual.
We'll let y transpose be CB
transpose times B inverse.
And then from the non-positivity of r,
it follows that y transpose D
has to be at least as
great as CD transpose.
And then we can show feasibility
by arguing that y transpose A, and
we can just rewrite that in
terms of sub matrices B and D.
Just by definition,
the first part is just CB transpose, and
the second part is this expression here,
which again, from our The fact that
our D is non positive
is at most Cb times T.
Well that's just our vector C and
we can see that y does in fact
meet the feasibility constraint.
Moreover, Y transposed B, that is the
objective function for the duel program.
Is equal to CV transpose
times B inverse, times B.
But B inverse B, that's equal to XB, and
C transpose B times XB was the value of
the objective function for the primal.
So these are equal, and
then by weak duality it follows
that our choice of Y is optimal.